so everywhere we see is marquee crash a
recession coming right the other day
they said 97 percent of fortune 500 ceos
are convinced we're either in recession
or it's coming so but what is scarier
than recession and market crash i'm
going to share with that here today and
by the way if you get value out of it
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel so last week
i'm at my annual convention okay
and i'm interviewing my new partner
brian adams who's the ceo and founder of
integrity marketing group it's a the
biggest insurance company that nobody
knows about and we're having this
conversation and he says he was having
dinner with jamie dimon okay
and during dinner with jamie dimon he
says hey so jamie
what are the what are the things you're
most concerned about right now with
today's economy recession market crash
all the stuff that's going on he says
the abcs of decay okay the abcs of decay
which is what
arrogance bureaucracy complacency he
didn't say bonds he didn't say rates he
didn't say china he didn't say
russia he didn't say politics he didn't
say he said arrogance bureaucracy
complacency so why why is that the
bigger concern by the way the abcs of
decay is also something that buffett's
been talking about for decades arrogance
bureaucracy and complacency so let's
bring it to you all right so go through
each one of them arrogance when people
make a lot of money they tend to get a
little too cocky they get arrogant you
know i'm bulletproof there's nothing
that can happen to me i'm so great
everybody tells me i'm so great i just
read a story yesterday company called
first guarantee i believe it's a
mortgage company last year in 2021 they
had their biggest year ever okay they
did 12 mil 12 billion dollars of loans
last year they hired that's 600
employees
they just fired 471 people in may and
they went out of business in june so
last year they're like this at their
meetings guys we're on top of the world
this year they found bankruptcy
stories being written out all over
bloomberg
arrogance gets you to not see your blind
spots and god knows we all have a lot of
blind spots number to bureaucracy what's
bureaucracy typically we we we had an
idea
and from idea to execution would take us
28 days okay let's just say now because
there's so many new people we've hired
we've gone from idea to execution in 28
days now it's 73 days now it's 198 days
approval the key is how can i take this
thing from idea to execution in 28 days
to 21 days to 19 days to 17 days but
what happens bureaucracies come
bureaucrats come in oh have you checked
with this guy check with that guy check
with this guy
again
arrogance bureaucracy and last but not
least is complacency complacency you're
casual you're no longer waking up at the
time you used to you're no longer taking
care of your help you're no longer
reading like used to that level of
obsession is gone you're no longer
thinking about what other ideas can we
do to grow the company to the next level
but regardless of what you and i do
recessions are going to happen every
five to 10 years market questions are
going to happen every five to 10 years
economy is going to get hit pandemics
are going to happen issues are going to
happen elections are going to happen
protesting is going to happen
none of that stuff is ever going to
permanently go away but what you can't
control is the abcs of decay arrogance
bureaucracy compliances and ask yourself
is any of those three something you guys
are going through right now individually
yourself or in your company if you are
address it as soon as possible if you
got value out of this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
and i did a video last year titled how
to crush your 22 business plan where i
talk about bureaucrats if you've never
seen this you may want to watch this
video take care everybody bye